As we switch from one's -- one Sprint to the next,
I want to note that the importance in this whole effort
of thinking through how partnerships will work with existing major project.
HathiTrust was invoked in this  -- they
and his team have been great supporters
and deeply involved in figuring out how we work with
and are ever -- interoperable with HathiTrust is  --
thank you for helping us see some of that through the
Beta Sprint.
The fifth is called metadata interoperability services.
The DPL a -- DPLA,  over to you guys.
Okay. Good afternoon.
Is our great pleasure to be here on this event
and we thank you very much for the invitation.
My name is Stephna Scolios.
We are heavily involved in the development in Europe over
the last several years, and the last four years, a.
What we're going to present today is a system.
We have implanted during this years,
and leaving this activity -- may be in order to define the scope,
I would like to say how it fits with what we have heard
in this session. Take for example the first presentation,
where you had the three big organizations,
that said they would like to share their content.
And presented through the DPLA.
What was implemented if I understood correctly it was
that gave a small number of data to the third one,
who used their own metadata
and president -- presentation schema to make the
presentation public. So think of the whole country.
So you have thousands of medium, small libraries,
different organizations, that represent their data,
their content through different schemas for example.
Libraries use code or mediate -- museums use -- your is used by archives.
And the different -- these different variations of this
schema represent their content,
based on specific usage of their content.
So you really need some mapping.
Especially on where you have all the data collected in
some place, but what really uses the metadata
and the presentations -- interoperability of access is gained through these mappings,
they can be at the semantic level,
the involvement of the use of experts at least in the
beginning of the organization to rip is in the mapping.
Based on this involvement with all this activity within
Europe, we implemented a system that will be percent now.
Hello. As you already learned,
I'm going to presenting the data services which is our --
I would also like to thank the DPLA steering committee
for encouraging us  to submit something for the DPLA.
We are of course happy that it can lead  to some cooperation between us.
So to start, services or -- supports aggregation workflow.
As we mentioned, mainly in the European region and typically,
these work to score -- corresponds three main states.
Mainly the first one is to gather providers without data, and in this step,
which means we are gathering metadata and materialization.
The second step is as the professor mentioned, to try to connect
or align the different provider metadata.
Aggregation data model, and Jew that,
we need visual editor for the -- in order for providers
to be able to implement and -- between their methods
and the aggregation and metadata schema.
Finally the third step is to --
This is essential -- this is a the -- you can see the
schema coming from the provider side.
When the right part is the aggregation target schema.
In this specific case,
it's the museum standard that is being used widely now in
Europe. While in the middle of the screen,
you see specific subject that corresponds to the selected
button, and it is actually the mapping area.
In order for a provider to map his data to the target
model, he actually needs to drag
and drop in this case we have a single one-to-one mapping.
Gets mapped to the title of the target schema.
This is done by drag and drop action
and every mapping action like that,
corresponds -- is translated to the team in the back,
so that you have a formal way to transform your data
between the two schemas and the -- that can be maintained and formalized.
The buttons and others, the user can perform conditional mappings,
structural mappings, string concatenation,
concatenation of elements and so on.
So in practice,
MINT has been used by several  aggregations in the European sector -- sector.
One of the first and most important ones is the Athena Project that
gathered over 5 million museum items from organizations
all over Europe including Russia and Israel.
And under this schema I mentioned earlier,
use green is a visual aggregator that offers support --
EU Screen. Certain ecological monuments
and signs with a special focus on 3-D digital resources for cultural activities.
Cross domain aggregations like Judaica Europena.
In digitization projects and so on.
Also MINT is used outside of aggregators for different
scope for supporting the evolution of the data models
like  prototype and European data model,
by the European in order to publish -- since most of
those schemas also have the semantic version of this,
focusing towards the lean data publication,
one of the first one is the link to data byte use green. -- By EUScreen.
And we are collaborating with other themes in order for
it to be reused. Through all these aggregations and projects,
we have gathered the growing number of common providers.
It's approximately 300 institutions and 500 users so far.
What we are learning together with them
and with the help us define and create services for is that aggregation corresponds
to domain experts.
Is the natural next step after annotation, and it's a step that is not a procedure, usually is ongoing.
And of course aggregation -- aggregators have envisioned
these past two years has led to the introduction of new
casts. And as a result, new services for cleaning, I can,
and reconciling. Apparently went too far.
We tried to help the DPLA to  design and operate
appropriate workflows for the delivery of metadata from the diverse institutions.
That you plant aggregate. And help providers agree to the DPL a -- DPLA layer
regardless of  different institutions, or the level of adoption of any DPLA requirements.
And of course, supports the natural evolution of data modeling with the
metadata schema itself. Or terminologies being used and so on.
I will not go on about that.
The people you can find more information here are the URL.
You can of course -- you are free to contact us,
and there is also the DPLA  Beta Sprint server where you
can use the mapping tool forr several other domains start of. Thank you very much.
[Applause]
We do have time for a couple questions for these
gentlemen who've come so far.
Thank you for traveling such a distance.
Trying to avoid strikes.
[Laughter].
We have some occupying protests and other things for you.
Actually, I live next to the major street. Like I never moved.
Another form of interoperability.
Exactly.
John Arnold from Massachusetts.
A quick easy question, -- geeky question,
are you actually doing that mapping at the sort of abstract schema level
or do you actually do it by examples
and do you think your system could learn by example by
having professional catalogers go for one other was an
example and let it learn what the --
It doesn't actually learn,
since it's really sensitive at list with the provider
that we used to work with to tell them that anything is happening automatically.
Or they want to be really sure that they can validate the
end results. So the idea is that usually on the target,
we have specific data model, usually a standard domain,
so it's something concrete while on the inputs we have
provided a to -- data that maybe standards,
maybe they think that it is standard but have customized it so it is standard home or.
Usually we work on the instance level.
That up let their specific connection.
Say you want to aggregate? That map it
and if they use it coherently throughout the organization,
they can use this stored mapping for subsequent inputs.
Sir, with a microphone, yes Sir?
Are the mappings themselves published as open data for
example as RDF triples for end,
can they be reused by others? Other applications?
For the time being, mappings of course they are stored
and people can download them
and load them in other instances. And of course,
they can share it to in them,
so we had the case especially with museums that they were
serving the same metadata schema,
so someone created the master template mapping.
And they use it as a template to create their own specialized mappings.
Now, as we see again through the aggregator evolution,
back in three, four years you're, asking,
give us were metadata records in the format that we are
suggesting. Now it seems that people tend -- and in general,
aggregators tend to ask for the original data together with we formalized mapping.
And mapping becomes a part of the data that is being transferred between institutions.
So yes, currently it's in excess of form,
but for schemas and links data publications,
there are subsequent mappings that can be also published
as RDF triples.
So your question -- the answer to your question is that
mapping yes,
becomes part of the total providers community.
Wonderful. Thank you both for coming.
[Applause]